but another recent poll finds a more
popular member of the administration is
a president's daughter Ivanka she moved
to Washington with her family after the
election she and her husband Jared
Kushner are both taken on senior roles
in the Trump White House in an interview
that you'll see only on CBS this morning
Ivanka Trump told us her unprecedented
position assistant to the president has
opened the door for her to have a major
impact when you spoke with 60 minutes
you said it was your intention to be a
daughter that you were not going to play
a role in the administration what
changed your mind when I spoke to 60
minutes it was I think five or six days
following the election and and I was
processing real time the new reality and
and what it would mean I realized that
having one foot in and one foot out
wouldn't work and the reality is it it
all happened very organically for me I
had to determine that my husband and I
would both want to be in DC that it was
viable to move our children that they
would be happy in their new environment
after I decided I wanted to try I needed
to divest of numerous businesses so did
my husband and I wanted to understand
where I could be an asset to the
administration how I could help my
father and ultimately the country what
were you be doing I think for me what it
means is that I'll continue the advocacy
work that I was doing in the private
sector advocating for the economic
empowerment of women I'm very focused on
the role of education I'm still my
father's daughter
so to me that this particular title was
about giving critics the comfort that
I'm holding myself to that highest
ethical standard but I'll weigh in with
my father on the issues I feel strongly
about you say that you are your father's
daughter and we all get that you also
talk about the critics and you have a
couple that say why isn't Ivanka
speaking out where is she on Planned
Parenthood where is she on gay rights
where is she on the rights of women
where is she on climate change and it's
like you're being held personally
accountable for not speaking up what do
you say to your
I would say not to conflate lack of
public denouncement with silence I think
there are multiple ways to have your
voice heard in some case it's through
protest and it's through going on the
nightly news and talking about or
denouncing every issue in which you
disagree with other times it is quietly
and directly and candidly so where I
disagree with my father he knows it and
I expressed myself with total candor
where I agree
I fully lean in and support the agenda
and hope that I can be an asset to him
and and make a positive impact but I
respect the fact that he always listens
it's how he was in business it's how he
is as president how much of a learning
curve is it for you for your father for
the Trump administration for me
tremendous the issues in this country
are so big and the problems are enormous
ly complicated but I am incredibly
confident in my father to be able to
execute on his promise to the people who
elected him and on the other side though
there are critics who are very worried
and who are very afraid who are
concerned about the direction that the
country is going in and what do you say
to those people we live in a very
polarizing time and do you think your
dad has contributed to that to the
polarization predates my father but I
think the election highlighted for
people just how divided this country was
I've seen many headlines that say Ivanka
and Jared are the moderating force in
the White House they have the
president's ear who is it that tells him
the hard truth is that you I do and
almost everyone he surrounds him was
with does that doesn't mean and and
again I think we're we're in a very
unique time where noise equals in a lot
of people's perception advocacy and I
fundamentally disagree with that I do
think there's a
time for public denouncement I also
think there's a time for discussion and
so you asked me about about people who
criticize me for not taking to social
media on every single issue and I would
ask them if that would render me more
effective or less effective with the
people ultimately making decision not
even necessarily social media but just
speaking up about things that I do I
speak up frequently and my father agrees
with me on so many issues and where he
doesn't he knows where I stand
but it's nervous integration of
something that you disagree with him on
and that you think that by speaking up
to him it made him change his position
or soften his position are you
comfortable with that I think that for
me this isn't about promoting my
viewpoints I wasn't elected by the
American people to be President I think
my father is going to do a tremendous
job and I want to help him do that but I
don't think that it will make me a more
effective advocate to constantly
articulate every issue publicly where I
disagree and that's okay that means that
I'll take hits from some critics who who
say that I should take to the street and
and and then other people will in the
long term respect where I've gotten
things done but I think most of the
impact I have over time most people will
not actually know about Wow really
interesting it was really interesting to
talk to her as you see she's very poised
she's very intelligent and as she points
out she's her father's daughter she will
never publicly say something negative
about her father but she definitely has
her ear that leaves us in the question
of what is it they differ on and we're
gonna think she is she is not she is not
going to share that information with me
anyway she's not sharing that
information but I think that that's
between her and her dad but what do you
think I think about climate change
certainly I think about gay rights I
think some of the immigration ban net
Parenthood and certainly Planned
Parenthood but she is not going to say
that publicly and she says you know I
can be very effective after all she can
walk into the Oval Office and say dad
mr. president I think your blah blah
blah blah blah really and we have a lot
more to come with them in our next half
hour we have a lot more to come to speak
with Ivana Trump there was so much to
discuss
it was very hard to get it all in 20
minutes she defends her husband and all
of the roles he has in the White House
plus she responds to criticism that she
is complicit in the new president's
agenda and she answers questions about
keeping her fashion business separate
from politics it's all ahead on CBS this
morning